while we are recording this bitcoin just
broke forty two thousand dollars
uh and you previously had identified
that as a pretty big resistance
what do you think happens from here
fully knowing that you can't uh predict
the future
but what is uh what is your thought
process as to where we go
yeah so like we've just broken
horizontals uh
resistance at 42k and then we've also
broken um
this diagonal resistance line if you
draw from like the wake up and
the 60k and then we also retested that
on the way down when we uh came back to
like we retested 60k and hit it and then
we retested it a couple days ago anyway
so
what i'm saying is we're we just broke
out of two
major um trend lines right so both
diagonally and invert
and uh horizontally so i think
there's really nothing but hair here
till about 48 k but i think the uh
the 200 a moving average is going to
give a bit of resistance and that's
right around 45k right now so
i'll be watching to see um you know we
might take a pause a little breather
there because
that's kind of a um a mark that a lot of
people in traditional finance look at
to see kind of like you know if an asset
is in like a bullish or bear phase i
guess you could say
um so yeah i would be looking for that
but i'm targeting right now
49 50k and seeing how we're going to
kind of react there over there you know
i
think it'll perhaps play out over the
coming weeks got it
is there anything that uh people should
be watching out for as we kind of
break through that 42 and on the way up
other than uh prices
is there anything on chain that you'll
look for
um just in general like one thing was
was the volume right we were talking
about how we want to see that pick up
um that's one thing and then also the
long term holder you don't want to see
them
dumping and you know just looking for
some kind of exit equity like we talked
about earlier um
sober stabilizing um and then in the
very short term just you can look at
futures
data just see how funding's looking um
you know look at
oi and just basic stuff like that for
like very short-term price movements
got it before i let you go everyone
loves when uh when will comes on people
even say will season uh what is uh
what's kind of your uh your final words
or anything you want to share with folks
uh hang in there guys this thing's gonna
pop
i love it i love it uh all right well
thank you so much for doing this every
week you're doing fantastic work as uh
i've told people i'd say without you
here
uh you by far i think are leading the
charge when it comes to unchained
metrics and
people are waking up to how important a
lot of that data is
so folks can go follow you on twitter or
subscribe to your newsletter where
should we send them on uh twitter or the
newsletter
yeah sure thanks for having me on man uh
i hope you guys get hyped again i know
this is a little
information uh heavy but i'll be
watching after i get off so you guys
better get the energy going again
uh you can find me on twitter at uh w
clementi iii
and then i have my newsletter is a btc
by wc3
sub stack dot com which is also in my
twitter bio
killing it man hey guys thanks so much
for watching that clip of the best
business show
make sure you like and subscribe to the
channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday
and then head to sofi.com so that you
can get an account
we can get after it